on sera tous donc je m'appelle laurent
rochette
je suis producteur de films ce soir je
vais vous parler d'un film que j'ai
produit mais je vais commencer par vous
parler de cinéma français alors je sais
pas si à l'évocation de ces deux mots
vous est gagné par un grand sentiment
d'ennui
sachez que moi aussi et si au contraire
vous trouvez que j'exagère que j'en fais
déjà trop qu'on a fait des super film en
france c'est vrai il y en a eu
on a écrit une belle page de l'histoire
du 20e siècle au cinéma en france
pourtant sur les 250 films de fiction
produit chaque année en france
je suis pas sûr qu'il va en rester
beaucoup
alors est ce que vous vous êtes déjà
demandé pourquoi le cinéma français
parlé aussi peu à notre génération
pourquoi on préfère regarder des séries
anglophone pour moi c'est l'incapacité
de faire sentir un rapport au monde qui
résonne en nous en gros ça nous touche
pas pourtant en vie
café particulier un an
notre présent et incertain parsemez de
crise politique financière humanitaire
notre futur est compromis par le
réchauffement climatique et les
conditions terribles que ça à voir sur
nos vies j'ai pas en train de vous faire
une belle intro suffit de regarder ce
qui s'est passé samedi à quelques mètres
d'ici ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
partout en france
en fait là le réel et le présent vient
vraiment frapper à la porte quoi alors
ça pouvait être autant d'objets et il
est possible pour des films tout ça
c'est des vrais questions qu'on se pose
pourtant cinéma français il ya des
kilomètres de ça alors je sais pas
pourquoi
comment on a essayé de faire
différemment
comment on a essayé de se s'écarter un
peu de la règle c'est à dire la règle
tacite qu'on devrait suivre quand on
fait un film
ce serait avoir un scénario un plan de
financement être à peu près quelqu'un
puis s'autocensurer pour voir des aides
comme on a essayé de se rapprocher même
un tout petit peu de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler l'exception
dans les films arrivent à se faufiler
entre la règle tu as entre les règles
pour se rapprocher un peu dollar
donner à sentir un rapport au monde et à
l'humanité qui trouve un écho en nous je
vais vous raconter comment on a tourné
produits et comment on va diffuser un
film qu'on aimerait voir au cinéma
un autre cinéma français on a commencé à
tourner en 2014
pendant une fête de la musique on a
choisi ce soir là parce que c'est un
soir où tout le monde est dans la rue
les gens sont alcoolisés des de la vie
partout c'est le soir le plus long et on
voulait être au contact de la vie on
était une équipe minuscule à peine 4 5
personnes qui on a continué comme ça
dans des événements jusqu'en 2017
jusqu aux obsèques de johnny hallyday
alors ça
être extrêmement en trois mois et demi
pour faire un film surtout quand on sait
que un long métrage de fiction ça sont
généralement entre 1 et 3 mois pourtant
ce temps c'était vraiment notre luxe
c'était notre culte parce que ça nous
permettait de fin vraiment d'évoluer en
même temps qu'une ville
c'est à dire de décrire et tourner à la
fois mais se laisser influencer par tout
ce qui se passait surtout à une époque
où
tout ça allait rendre le projet quand
même assez vertigineux d'ailleurs
pendant qu'on tournait en 2016
tombé sur une pub pour une montre de
luxe dans le métro et dessus il y avait
un tag c'était marqué vous avez la
montre on a le temps c'est vrai qu'on
n'avait pas la montre j'irai même plus
loin je dirais même qu'on avait la
chance de ne pas avoir d'argent
beaucoup de foi en un producteur vous
dire ça mais pour nous c'était une
chance parce que pas avoir d'argent ça
voulait dire pas avoir de dispositifs de
tournage monstrueux
comme tous ces camions vous voyez bloqué
des rues dans paris pas avoir d'argent
c'est aussi donc la poésie d'être
invisible mais d'être une toute petite
équipe sans hiérarchie est tous au même
niveau
et surtout pas avoir d'argent c'est la
possibilité de pouvoir échouent et
d'échouer vraiment
commencée le pouvoir échouent et encore
mais d'échouer mieux
en fait c'est la possibilité de pouvoir
expérimenter c'est chercher un style un
langage et tout ça sans arrière pensées
commerciales son business plan
mais alors comment on fait concrètement
pour faire un film
car on était juste un petit groupe de
personnes on se connaissait pas tous
forcément mais on avait confiance
mutuelle et surtout on avait la
conscience de la liberté qui n'était
donnée à ce moment là
par exemple
on travaille tous dans le cinéma ça le
faisait bénévolement
si je prends les acteurs
dans un film traditionnel des acteurs
ce sol il on line là il l'a
assistant dit ça tourne
mon moteur dans l'autre sens mais
l'acteur rentrer dans la pièce il va à
sa première marque et donne sa réplique
il va sa deuxième marque
il sort de la pièce coupe et on
recommence
c'était pas du tout ça l'acteur il n'est
pas pour cachetonner pour se déplacer
d'une marque à l'autre
il n'est pas ce qu'il y avait un film
important à faire parce qu'il y avait
des questions à se poser
c'est lui qui guide l'action c'était ses
mots dans sa bouche
il avait une responsabilité
alors on a continué et puis
on se dit que ce qui serait bien ce
serait mettre la technique au service de
tout ça que ce soit plus un frein
vous voyez on a de la chance comme avec
l'évolution du numérique non avec vos
téléphones portables vidéo que ça peut
faire
et imaginer des toutes petites caméras
de cinéma qu'on pouvait pas ce qu'on
pourrait faire si on les met au contact
du réel dans la vie
je vais laisser la parole à l'actrice du
film noémie schmitt s'explique très bien
ce dispositif je pense
au cinéma pour reproduire la vie réelle
il faut des moyens incroyable nous au
contraire on a pensé que ce qui serait
incroyable c'est d'amener le cinéma dans
la vie réelle on n'avait pas de moyens
alors on a cherché le plus petit
dispositif possible pour se fondre dans
la ville au lieu de reproduire la
réalité on essayait de complètement de
l'intégrer ça veut dire aussi qu'on
attaque à contrôler ce qui se passe et
où la caméra et on a cherché à dans des
endroits où il se passait des choses
or un film traditionnel tous ces gens
qu'on a autour de nour et des figurants
alors qu'avec ce dispositif tout peut
arriver
le real vient complètement balayé la
fiction c'est comme ça qu'on peut faire
ressentir le vertige psychologique qui
m'angoisse et l'appareil ne regarde mon
personnage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après trois ans et demi après trois ans
et demi on avait un premier montage des
images et on se rapprocher de plus en
plus de la finalisation du film ce qu'on
appelle la postproduction et qui
nécessite des moyens techniques et
humains qu'on peut céder pas parce que
même si on faisait un film sans moyens
fallait que ce soit un film de cinéma
quand même et qu'on soit à la hauteur de
ça donc on s'est dit pourquoi pas aller
chercher des coproducteurs des gens qui
ont de l'argent en france trophée
indéfini en a plein
on a envoyé des mails m'a appelé
peu une seule réponse
seul
en fait le projet qu'on lançait
impensable pour faire un film sans aide
sans chaînes de télé sans scénario ça
des kilomètres de ce qu'ils font
on était un peu bloquée en fait
on a réfléchi on s'est demandé pour qui
est ce qu'on faisait le film
ce qu'on fait ce film pour
ti milieu du cinéma parisien
parce qu'il peut toucher un public
on avait notre réponse
alors on a décidé de lancer une campagne
motif
j'ai pas certains d'entre vous ont déjà
fait du crowdfunding mais on sait tous
que généralement on commence toujours
par demander de l'argent à sa famille et
à ses potes
bon bah dans notre cahier séparément
dans le cinéma et c'est que ce serait
quand même assez sympa devra expliquer
simplement ce projet un peu obscur qu'on
faisait depuis quatre ans on a décidé de
faire une vidéo
voilà
vidéo elle a été vue 4 millions de fois
sur facebook
c'est un choc
en fait c'était un choc énorme de voir
que initiative qu'on lançait l'histoire
qu'on voulait raconter ça pouvait
toucher autant notre génération mais
aussi celle de nos petites soeurs nos
petits frères surtout quand on les dit
pas vraiment intéressés par la culture
ou par le cinéma ou vraiment dans un
clip de l'instantané pourtant c'est pas
vrai ce qu ont plébiscité un projet de
film aussi expérimentale
grassin que le film a eu autant de
visibilité alors on vous a demandé
comment on fait un buzz comment on fait
un buzz
c'est rien n'a jamais
chien faire un buzz on a juste voulu
partager sincèrement notre expérience
après peut-être contre s'est posé des
questions qui a résonné chez certaines
personnes aussi en gros dans la suite de
la vidéo que j'allais vous montrer nos
amis marche dans la rue elle se pose une
question est le elle demain elle se
demande si on peut croire en l'avenir
quand la peur nous déterminent voilà
c'était peut-être cette question car la
zone est fier des gens
donc en fait c'est
vidéo elle allait prendre conscience
qu'on a un public enfin qu'on a un vrai
qu'on a développé un public finalement
et nous on voulait que les gens et accès
aux films aussi facilement qu'ils ont eu
accès à cette vidéo alors on est des
propositions distributeurs
ça se limitait sur une sortie très
confidentiel sur très peu de salles très
peu d'écrans
ça nous allait pas
en fait on se rendait compte que
l'industrie même après cette vidéo le
succès
pas du tout à saisir l'évolution des
modes de visionnage chez nous ou encore
notre envie de voir des formes nouvelles
des formes radicales des formes qui
questionne le monde
réfléchis un peu sur nous aussi et on a
compris qu'on était vraiment la première
génération avoir développé notre
cinéphilie sur internet c'est dans notre
amour du cinéma en regardant des films
en entendant parler mais grâce à
internet on va beaucoup au cinéma voir
des films d'art et d'essai mais on sait
que c'est de moins en moins le cas dans
notre génération
partout en france puis on a surtout
réfléchir au sens du mot cinéma c'est ce
que c'est le cinéma le cinéma ça des
signes est un lieu le cinéma l'endroit
on va voir des films mais je crois
qu'avant toute chose le cinéma ça
définit un médium un art le septième art
et que le lieu est moins important que
l'art
même si le lieu est bien sûr important
mais ce qui va rester c'est les films
pas forcément les lieux
donc assez paradoxalement
on a décidé de signer avec netflix pour
la diffusion du film
seulement parce que
font un cinéma plutôt très libre très
indépendant
on se retrouve à signer avec l'un des
géants du web
on est ultra méfiants concernant
l'utilisation des algorithmes mais au
final on se retrouve
même beaucoup plus proche de netflix que
de tous les tenants de la culture dite
classique qui refusent même de penser un
tel projet
que ça puisse exister de le voir quoi
le film sort en début d'année et on est
très curieux de voir comment il va être
reçus parce que c'est assez marrant
d'envoyer un truc aussi libre comme ça
sur une plateforme comme netflix donc
pour nous c'est vraiment
l'expérimentation qui continue
et en guise de conclusion j'aimerais
dire que c'est toujours important
d'essayer de faire des choses même
gratuitement dans notre cas c'est
récompensé parce que on signe avec
netflix
on paye tout une équipe qui a bossé
bénévolement
mais même en dehors de ça je pense que
c'est vraiment important d'essayer de
faire des choses de questionner notre
rapport au monde
questionner notre présent sur cette
planète
sans forcément avoir la volonté de
discuter c'est pas ça mais c'est qu'on
vit une époque particulière et qu'il
faut se poser des questions
je pense que le cinéma et que l'art
permet ça mais ce n'est pas la seule
chose
et puis surtout
si on nous laisse pas faire
surtout pas demandé la permission à
demander qu'on soit d'accord pour le
faire il faut juste le faire
cible pense qu'il faut pas hésiter à
mettre le pied dans la porte voilà merci
à vous
[Applaudissements]